and we will start right off with the
first part which is the introduction to
system modeling here we'll go through
the basic the most basic parts of system
modeling talk a bit about valle frances
the modeler and how it fits into all of
this we will also talk about what you
need to get up and running with all this
new functionality but most importantly
in this part we'll cover the most
important thing which is the system
models the actual models that we will be
interacting with today we will find out
how you can browse the built in model
repository in order to find models that
you can simulate that you can modify and
analyze and also how you can import new
models into your voltron language
session so let's start with fall from
system model what is valle frances the
modeler it is a standalone product from
wolfram mathematica and other more from
language products and it's a graphical
user interface that allows you to create
arbitrarily complex models from any
number of different domains including
electrical mechanical thermal biological
models and so on and I think I'll jump
into system model a bit to show you how
it looks so you can get a feeling for
what a system model is now actually this
first new command that I'm running from
my evolve from Mathematica notebook here
will actually not be available to evolve
from just foreign language uses those
that don't have a copy of system
modeling installed but and that is
because it opens up system model itself
so that's pretty logical and so once I
run this command
and you'll notice that for you
existing system oddly uses you'll notice
that I didn't need to call the the WSM
link package that you might be used to
calling now all of these functions are
built into the vault from language they
will just be there from the from the
start so you can just type them into the
session and the Wolfram language will
recognize that no need to load any
additional package or anything like that
so we call this system model function e
willow with without any arguments it
would just open up a blank session of
system habla and this is what it looks
like and what system model is it's a
tool that's flexible enough to build
anything from a simple circuit for
example let's see if we can find a DC
motor this some of them here a simple
electrical circuit like this one
this DC motor and you build models of
different things in system modeler just
by dragging and dropping different
components onto the canvas and then
connecting them up together with the
ports in the case of an electrical
circuit it's you're connecting it kinda
like yeah you're creating an electrical
connection between the different
components and in the case of a
mechanical system like this inertia here
it's a mechanical system that's attached
to the DC motor then you connect them
things like a solid mechanical
connection now this is very simple a
simple example of a model we can scaled
it this up to something which has for
for example thousands of different
components we could look at the model of
a car drive line instead and on the
surface this model milton system model
it might not look so complicated but in
system modeler in order to be able to
build these highly detailed models
without actually
risking fluttering things up you build
you build things hierarchically you
build them using like a normal how how
things would look normally where your
example could collect everything
everything needed to model a trans
transmission you could collect that in
one component and then have smaller
components that describe how this car
transmission work so you have a
component that is the automatic control
unit and you have one component for a
gearbox and these can even have even
smaller even smaller components so this
is how the graphical user interface of
system model allows you to create these
arbitrarily complex models ranging from
very simple to very very advanced using
just a simple drag-and-drop methodology
and I forgot to mention but the
components that you use here they are
they're all provided built-in to system
modeler from many different domains such
as electrical mechanical thermal
biological and so on however today in
this session we won't be as concerned
with how these models are built we will
instead assume that you have a model
that you want to analyze in some way you
might want to optimize this carb drive
car drive line you might want to test
how reliable this DC motor is to
different types of scenarios then we
usually we can use Duvall from language
to try these models in different
scenarios and that is what we'll learn
about today so I'll switch back to my
Wolfram language session here and
I mentioned in the introduction well
it's it has previously been possible to
connect sister muddler with the vole
from language using a package previously
called WSM link now we're fully
integrating the simulation engine from
system model ed that is what allows you
to actually take these models analyze
them simulate them visualize them and so
on and we're fully integrating it into
Mathematica 11.3 and this means that we
have a completely new system modeling
interface so this function here it's
completely new and all the functions I
will be showing today are brand new for
eleven point three and they have
expanded and streamlined capabilities
compared to the old functions that were
present in pwm link package and as I
also mentioned this allows you to do a
lot of these the simulation and analysis
of models without having a copy of
system modeler with just having a copy
of the vol from language and it allows
you to send if your models developed
working in system or modeler that would
also allow you to send these models for
anyone any other foreign language user
to pick up explore analyze and visualize
and so on but first I need to start with
a bit of system requirements now in
terms of systems that is isn't a problem
evolved from system model involved from
Mathematica they both run on the same
types of system the the included
simulation engine it works for Windows
Mac OS Linux so all the major all the
major platforms so if you're able to run
Mathematica or any other Wolfram
language desktop product today
then you should be able to use this
functionality however one small caveat
is that you need to install a compiler
and you might wonder why this is needed
and in order to take all these you know
advanced system models for example take
a model of a car which might have
thousands of different components and
then making it so that you can run these
models very efficiently and simulate
them very quickly then we translate
those models those equations that form
up those models we translate that into
highly optimized C++ code and then
compile it into a standalone executable
and with this we want to ensure that
even for very large systems they can be
similar very quickly so there's some
built-in
steps in order to configure a compiler
for Windows there's even a built-in
workflow where you can just click click
install and it should install the
compiler and once you've done that you
can verify verify that you have a
compiler that system modeler recognized
up running and this will send out these
notebooks I want to go array through
what each of these does but there's some
a full list of instructions for
installing these compilers are available
in this presentation notebook that we
sent out right now if we want to
simulate these models and we want to
visualize them how exactly do we find
them now system older comes with a wide
range of pre-built models I've shown you
two right now DC motor and a model of a
car drive line but I think there's
there's hundreds of maybe thousands
other built-in simulation models that
you can run just straight from straight
from your Wolfram language session and
you can browse all of these with a new
system model examples command command
and this one provides you once it's
loaded it provides you with an
interactive interface we can explore
different packages in system modeler or
rather the system modeler engine that is
included in the Voltron language so even
if you don't have system modeler you can
still call this system model examples
function and find all the currently
loaded runnable simulation models and
they are organized into different
packages so we have some packages for
different educational domains for
example so in electrical engineering we
can find different runnable different
runnable models for example a boost
converter and this will this will only
look at the models that are that you can
take and start to simulate directly so
that's one way of finding finding a
model now if you already know what
you're looking for you can use the sis
the new system model command and call a
with a string ask for a student model
and this might look a bit unconventional
it uses dots to separate these packages
that I showed previously in the in the
Explorer so if you have education
examples that's your top package then
dot electrical engineering so that's one
down one step in the package and then
another dot and you'll find the model so
we can call this one and
what we'll get back then is a system
model object now the these are
completely new in 11.3 and they provide
you with different ways to to interact
with this model it's a you can think of
it as a representation of a model that
is loaded into system modeler and will
make use of these modern representations
pretty soon now if the name is unique
such as this buck boost converter you
can just ask for buck boost converter
and then you'll get back exactly the
same exactly the same model now this
also has autocomplete so if you're for
example say you're looking for an engine
then you could start typing in engine
and it would find some different
different types of engine models that
are currently loaded in the system Ola
so here we'll get v6 engine model that
we can simulate and run if now you might
have more more more than one model
that's called a certain thing and if
they exist in different packages this is
perfectly allowed but if you then try to
use a short name to call the model
you'll get an error but it will list all
the available models that is called
rectifier so we have some different
types of rectifiers that we can that we
can get a model representation of so say
we want a multi-phase rectifier then we
could call it by the complete name
instead and we'll get the model
representation of that
so the models here that have been
showing they are well you use
drag-and-drop to create them what is
actually happening is that the graphical
user interface is creating something
that's called Metallica code or well
code that's written the Metallica
language and this is a non-proprietary
language that is used to describe
different set different the different
systems of equations and it's it's
pretty simple when you look at the most
the most fundamental the most
fundamental components for example a
this just a model of a different simple
differential equation you just type down
the equations and you can do this for
yourself in the using a using the
built-in text tool in system modeler or
you can create models using drag and
drop and these equations and everything
you need to accurately model your system
will be created for you but it's pretty
nice you can actually it's human
readable so you can find out exactly
what is happening inside the model and
since it's completely text-based you can
get out a string from your from your
model which is pretty nice if you're
doing revision control and so on so I I
only showed you now the models that are
built into the system oddly onion those
that you will have access to once you
just as soon as you load up your vol
from language session you will have
access to those models now there's since
there's a lot of lots of other sources
for models that you can find if we
publish a lot of
all examples on the system on the
webpage the vote from library store
provides you with different ways to
extend the modeling capabilities of
system model and also contains a lot of
different runnable models the vault from
community is a great source of of models
that you can import into your engine and
now and of course models that you create
yourself either using the graphical user
interface of open system modeler
or if you are creating models from the
Voltron language now that is also
possible and and I will cover that later
in this session however since the
language is non proprietary there are
also non ball from sources that you can
get models from and the Metallica
Association can maintains a list of
different model libraries that you can
download and import into system habla
and if you don't have system modeler you
can still import import these models
that you download from the web or so on
you just use the normal import command
in involve foreign language and say that
it's a model file and often language
will recognize that and then load that
model into your system modeler session
now there's a new function in 11.3 which
is pretty nice which is called icon eyes
and since these system modelers there
are a system model sorry
they are just model like us they're just
text based you can pretty easily embed
that text inside of a ball from language
notes book and you can use the you can
use the icon eyes command to do this so
if I asked for the string of the
of this sister model I will get back
there that string involved from language
representation and I'll call I can dice
and I'll get back an ionized
representation of that string now I can
completely embed this in the model and
for example have a function at the
beginning of my notebook or so on that
takes this string and imports it into
the into the system model engine session
so now I've imported a this differential
equation and I can I can find it in the
in the browser I showed previously or I
can see if I switch to system modeler I
can see that it has been has been loaded
now one thing I might not have made
clear is that system habla and the ball
from language these two these two
sessions here they are working on
they're using a shared state so
everything that happens in the volt from
language when I say to import this the
it will it would immediately be
available in system habla